- [Male Voice] Previously
on Bro Dependent,
- Now to say a few words
his eldest son, Anderson.
- Fucking sucks, am I right.
He had a nice dick.
Bummer City, population,
like my loved ones.
- Nice dude.
- That's my fucking sister dude.
- What?
- I know she's playing
all like cute and sweet
with you right now, but she's a
fucking predator dude.
She's like a cute little Wilt Chamberlain.
(upbeat music)
- Fuck!
Fuck!
Fuck, fucking fuck.
Fuck dude, stop putting it in the corner,
I can't, no one can get it out of there.
Fuck dude, you're like destroying me.
- Yeah, I have a killer forehand.
- Zach, what's wrong dude?
You're winning.
You're like making a mockery of
my normally devastating return game.
Why are you emoting?
- My dad got me with this
super top notch agency
and I'm just like getting a
fuck load of opportunities.
- Dude, like chin up
buddy, that's good man.
- Yeah, I'm like super connected
to my instrument or whatever,
but, like, do you know
what an audition is?
You have to like drive there and like
know your lines and shit.
- Hey, you guys done?
- [Both Men] Fuck off!
- What?
What?
- What's going on?
Fuck, get the fuck out of here dude.
- We're busy, we're playing racquetball.
- Go fuck your wife.
(laughter)
- It's your serve dude.
Honestly dude, I can't help but be like a
little jealous of you, you know?
Like, you look like a talent.
I feel sort of like lost, you know
in the woods, you know, of my brain.
Fuck dude.
It's like my footwork is so good
how do you keep beating me?
- Dude, it's not a competition
can't you just like commiserate with me?
- Yeah, I'm sorry, that driving
stuff sounds like shitty.
Why don't you just like not go, you know?
- Cuz my dad will pull
my allowance if I don't.
- Fuck dude!
What the fuck was that?
- That's game.
- Fuck, fucking piece of shit.
- Anderson, you just
gotta like ask yourself
what do I love?
- I do dude.
And, like I love hanging out with you
and like doing drugs
but like we already hang out
and all the drugs have been invented.
It's pretty messed up man.
Luckily I was able to like fuck
most of my worries into Marti last night.
Her pussy's like my therapist dude.
(laughing)
- Haha nice dude.
- Oh yeah, it was just like, oh, oh,
you like that?
Do you like how that sex feels?
(laughter)
- Dude I'm so happy for you.
- Yeah dude. I do some
pretty good work in there.
Hey, you could have the
leftovers tonight if you want.
- Oh no dude, she's all yours, I'm good.
- What?
- You can't smoke in here.
- We're not done dudes.
- You're not supposed to
be eating food either.
- Oh, I'm sorry, dad.
- Sorry I'm breaking all
the rules, Tommy Bahama.
- Dude, I like your goggles dudes
did you buy those together?
Did you go to Oakley together?
- Are you like swimmers?
(laughter)
- Hey dude, what did you
mean Marti's all mine?
- Dude, I spent last night in your sister,
and I gotta say, I'm floating on air.
The first time in my life, it was like
I wasn't just fucking, I was making love.
- Oh.
- I fucking cried when I came dude.
- Fuck, ow dude.
Stop serving so hard.
- I don't want to say
that I'm in love with her,
but, I'm definitely
falling in love with her.
- Fuck.
Jesus, Andre Agassi.
About Carolyn like she's my sister.
I've watched her fuck
up like a hundred guys.
You just fucked her once.
I'm not gonna let her do that
to my best friend, all right?
- If you were my best friend
you would want me to be happy.
I want something with substance, dude.
You had that.
- And she died, dude.
- Yeah, I'm aware dude, you never
stop fucking talking about it.
- Fuck you dude!
- Ow dude! Aaaah.
- Dude, I'm sorry, but you're not supposed
to talk shit of the dead dude.
- What the hell's going on in here?
Do I smell weed?
[Both] Fuck you.
- Can't you see we're like fighting.
- Zach, are we fighting?
- I don't know, are we?
- Ow!
- Yeah, I guess we are.
I fall for someone and you're all like
no dude don't do that.
Thanks friend.
- Dude, Zach, I just,
- Fuck you.
- Fuck you dude.
- No dude, I mean it.
Like in a mean way, Fuck you.
- Guys! Get your stuff and
get out of here right now.
- Zach.
Fuck.
Oh that's very mature guys.
Very funny, who does that?
(upbeat music)
- Hey, thanks for watching Bro Dependent
on Comedy Centrals' YouTube channel.
If you like what you saw,
comment, tell us about it,
uh subscribe to Comedy
Centrals' YouTube channel
and go see more Bro Dependent episodes
which are similar but different
on Comedycentral.com
Feels so weird doing this without Zach.
Like he should be here.